siento que el tribunal constitucional de
ese país declaró fundada la demanda de
habas Corpus presentada por el
presidente Pedro Castillo porque
considera que la acusación de traición a
la patria formulada por el parlamento
peruano carece de fundamentación
objetiva no esa corre con los parámetros
de razonabilidad y transgrede el debido
proceso en la sede parlamentaria en
realidad diversos juristas ya venían
criticando este procedimiento del
Congreso peruano porque señalan ellos
que el presidente Pedro Castillo jamás
violó la ley peruana ni tampoco violentó
la Constitución Política de este país al
ofrecer una salida al mar a Para Bolivia
durante una entrevista que brindó a
enero de este año señalan que solamente
fueron declaraciones palabras opiniones
y en ese país opinar no es delito
entonces por eso convalidan la decisión
del tribunal constitucional Pero bueno
qué es lo que viene ahora este esta
sentencia el tribunal constitucional le
arruina los planes a compositores del
presidente Castillo en el parlamento
porque ahora van a necesitar recurrir a
un proceso de vacancia presidencial o un
impeachment para tratar de sacarle el
cargo al presidente castillo y para
ellos se necesitan se necesitan 87 votos
que ahorita no pueden reunirlos Esa es
la situación bueno y sabemos
cita de la misión de alto rango de la
oea que está analizando la crisis
política del país que avances hay en esa
materia
bueno como usted lo he dicho la misión
de la oea en el grupo de alto nivel
culmina hoy su reuniones dos días con
las diversas autoridades de este país
hay que señalar que ha habido algunas
pequeñas protestas contra la oea de
diversos bandos tanto de Los Seguidores
de Pedro Castillo como los de Seguidores
de los congresistas en la misión de alto
nivel ha reunido tanto con el gobierno
de Pedro Castillo con los líderes del
Congreso y con otros integrantes de la
sociedad peruana ellos han recabado los
informes Pero hay algunos sectores que
señalan que la misión de alto nivel
también debió recibir a la contraloría
este país para tener un aporte lo que es
el nivel de corrupción en esta nación y
así tener una idea general de Cómo
afrontar la crisis peruana y cuáles son
los otros estamentos que también deben
tener presente El Vocero de esta
comisión de alto nivel Eladio loaizaga
ha señalado que el informe las
conclusiones recién serán dadas a
conocer en unos días cuando ellos se
presenten ante la comisión permanente de
la Organización de Estados Americanos y
ahí sabremos Cómo se va a tratar esta
crisis política en el Perú que hasta el
momento no se soluciona y lleva
paralizado al país desde hace ya meses
atrás desde que asumió el presidente
Pedro que ha sido